e la disputa entre francia y reino
unido- por las licencias pesqueras parís
anunció este viernes que reclamará a la
unión europea llevar un proceso
contencioso contra londres el anuncio se
hizo tras la reunión en el elíseo entre
el presidente de manuel macrón y
pescadores franceses y representantes
del gremio el mandatario evocó las
consecuencias del break 7 en reino unido
específicamente el conflicto que surgió
entre ambas partes relacionado con las
licencias de los pescadores franceses
que trabajan en aguas británicas
durante 11 meses negociamos de buena fe
con determinación con los británicos y
con los presidentes de las regiones
interesadas ya hemos obtenido el 93 por
ciento de las licencias de pesca
aun quedan algunas decenas de licencias
por obtener son muchos barcos y muchas
familias que debemos defender
absolutamente según lo firmado en el
break sit entre el reino unido y la
unión europea los pescadores europeos
pueden seguir trabajando en aguas
británicas a partir de la obtención de
una licencia
creo que el presidente macrón tuvo muy
claro que la lucha sigue y no parará
cuando hayamos obtenido todas las
licencias nos dijo que no quiere dejar y
también propuso que tal vez haya una
negociación que puede ser más local como
por ejemplo con la isla de jersey
francia asegura que aún faltan 73
permisos de pesca para que el conflicto
con reino unido- termine por su parte de
londres asegura que los pescadores que
carecen de la documentación requerida
para obtener la licencia son los que no
han logrado obtener este permiso además
deben demostrar que ya pescaban en sus
aguas el sector pesquero es una
industria relativamente pequeña pero
simbólicamente importante tanto para el
reino unido como para francia